i have here three equations of four
unknowns and you can already guess or
you already know that if you have more
unknowns than equations you're probably
not constraining it enough so you're
actually going to have an infinite
number of solutions but those infinite
number of solutions could still be
constrained within well let's say that
this is let's say we're in four
dimensions in this case because we have
four variables maybe we're constrained
into a plane in four dimensions or if
we're in three dimensions maybe we're
constrained to a line a line is an
infinite number of solutions but it's
kind of a more constrained set so let's
solve this set of linear equations and
we've done this by elimination in the
past but what i want to do is i want to
introduce the idea of matrices and the
matrices are really just arrays of
numbers that are shorthand for this
system of equations so let me create a
matrix here so i could just create a
coefficient matrix
where the coefficient matrix would just
be
let me write it neatly
the coefficient matrix would just be
the coefficients on the left-hand side
of of these linear equations so the
coefficient there is one
coefficient there is one coefficient
there is two and you have 2 2 4
2 2
1 2
0 1 2 there's no coefficient on the x 3
term here because it's there's no x 3
term there so we'll say the coefficient
on the x 3 term there is 0
and then we have 1 minus 1
minus 1 and 6. now if i just
did this right there that would be the
coefficient matrix for this system of
equations right there but what i want to
do is i want to augment it i want to
augment it with what these equations
need to be equal to so let me augment it
and what i'm going to do is i'm just
draw a little line here
and write the 7
the 12
and the 4. and i think you can see that
whatever
this right here is just another way of
writing this and just by the position we
know that these are the coefficients on
the x1 terms we know that these are the
coefficients on the x2 terms and what
this does it really just saves us from
having to write x1 and x2 every time but
we can essentially do the same
operations on this that we otherwise
would have done on that so what we can
do is we can
replace any equation with that equation
times some scalar multiple plus another
equation we can divide an equation or
multiply an equation by scalar we can
subtract them from each other we can
swap them so let's do that in an attempt
to solve this equation so the first
thing i want to do just like i've done
in the past is i want to get this
equation to the form of where if i can i
have a 1 my kind of leading coefficient
in any of my rows is a 1 and that every
other every other every other entry in
that column is a zero and in the past i
made sure that every other entry below
it is a zero that's what i was doing in
some of the previous videos when we
tried to figure out if things were
linear linearly independent or not but
now i'm going to make sure that if
there's a one in if there's a leading
one in any of my rows that everything
else in that column is a zero and that
what i'm calling with that that form i'm
doing is called reduced row echelon form
let me write that reduced
row
echelon
form
and if we call this augmented matrix
matrix a then i want to get it into the
reduced row echelon form of matrix a and
matrices the convention is just like
vectors you make them nice and bold but
use capital letters instead of lowercase
letters we'll talk more about how
matrices relate to vectors in the future
but let's just solve this system of
equations
so the first thing i want to do is in an
ideal world i would get all of these
guys right here to be 0. so let me
let me replace this guy
with that guy with the first entry minus
the second entry so let me do that
so
i am just going to
the first row isn't going to change it's
going to be 1 2
and then i get a
seven right there that's my first row
now the second row i'm going to replace
it with the first row minus the second
row
so what do i get
one minus one is 0
2 minus 2 is 0
1 minus 2 is minus 1
and then 1 minus minus 1 is 2
right that's 1 plus 1 and then 7 minus
is minus 5.
all right now i want to get rid of this
row here or i don't want to get rid of
it i want to get rid of this 2 right
here i want to turn it into a 0.
so let's replace this row
with this row minus 2 times that row
so what i'm going to do is this row
minus 2 times the first row and i'm
going to replace this row with that
so 2 minus 2 times 1 is 0. that was the
whole point
four
minus two times two is zero
zero
minus two times one
is minus two
six
minus two times one
is six minus two which is four
and then four minus two times seven is
four minus fourteen
which is
minus ten
all right now what can i do next
well i d let's see i don't have any well
this guy you can kind of see this rose
kind of well we'll talk more about what
this row means when all of a sudden it's
just all been zeroed out there's nothing
here if i had a non-zero term here then
i'd want to zero this guy out although
it's already zeroed out so i'm just
going to move over to this row so the
first thing i want to do is i want to
make this leading this leading
coefficient here a 1.
so what i want to do is i'm going to
multiply
i'm going to multiply this entire row by
minus 1.
so if i multiply this entire row times
-1 in fact i don't even have to rewrite
the matrix this becomes plus 1
minus 2
plus 5. i think you can accept that
all right now what can we do well let's
turn this right here into a zero so let
me
rewrite my augmented matrix
in the new form that i have so i'm going
to keep the middle row the same this
time so my middle row is 0
minus 2 and then it's augmented and i
get a 5 there
and what i want to do is i want to
i want to eliminate this minus 2 here so
why don't i add this row to 2 times that
row right then i would have minus 2 plus
2 and that will work out
so what do i get i get a well these are
just leading zeros
and then i have
minus two
plus two times one well that's just zero
four
plus two times minus two
four plus two times minus two that's
minus four
so that's four plus minus four
that's zero as well
and then you have minus ten
plus two times five well that's just
minus ten plus ten which is zero
so that one just got zeroed out and what
i want to do and normally when i just
did regular elimination i was happy just
you know having the situation where i
just had these leading ones everything
below it were zeros but i wasn't too
concerned about what was above our ones
but what i want to do is i want to make
those into a zero as well
so i want to make this guy
a zero as well so what i can do is
i can replace this first row with that
first row minus the second row so what
is
one minus zero well that's just one
two minus zero
is two
one minus one is
zero
one minus minus two
is three
seven minus five
is two
and there you have it
we have our matrix in reduced row
echelon form this is the reduced row
echelon form
of our matrix i'll write it in bold of
our matrix a right there and you know
it's in reduced row echelon form because
all of your leading ones
in each row so what are my leading ones
in each row i have this one and i have
that one they're the only non-zero entry
in their columns and these are called
the pivot entries
these are let me label that for you
that's called a pivot entry
pivot
entry they're the only non-zero entry in
their respective columns
if i have any zeroed out rows and i do
have a zero dot row it's right there
so this is zeroed
zeroed out row
just the styled or just the convention
is that it for reduced row echelon form
that has to be your last row so we have
the leading entries are the only they're
all one and that's one case you can't
have this a five you'd want to divide
both you would divide that equation by
five if this was a five so your leading
entries in each row are one
that the leading entry in each
successive row is to the right of the
leading entry of the row before it right
this guy right here is to the right of
that guy this is just the style the
convention of reduced row echelon form
and if you have any zeroed out rows it's
in the last row and then finally of
course and i think i've said this
multiple times this is the only non-zero
entry in the row
now what does this do for me well now i
can go back from this world back to my
linear equations because we remember
that these were the coefficients on x1
these were the coefficients on x2 these
are the coefficients on x3 on x4 and
then these were my constants out here so
i can rewrite this system of equations
using my reduced row echelon form as
x1
plus 2 x 2 there's no x 3 there so plus
x 4
is equal to 2
and then this equation no x 1 no x 2 i
have an x 3
i have x 3
minus 2
x 4
is equal to
and then i have no other equation here
this one got completely zeroed out so i
was able to reduce this set of this
system of equations to this system of
equations
now the variables that you associate
with your pivot entries we call these
pivot variables
so
x1 and x3 are pivot variables
pivot
variables
and then the variables that aren't
associated with a pivot entry we call
them free variables so x2
and x4
are free
variables
but now let's let's solve for
essentially you have to only you can
only solve for your pivot variables the
free variables we can set to any
variable and you can i said that in the
beginning of this equation we have fewer
equations than unknowns so this is going
to be
a not well constrained solution you're
not going to have just one point in r4
that solves this equation you're going
to have multiple points
so let's solve
let's solve for our pivot variables
because that's all we can solve for so
this equation tells us
right here
it tells us x3 let me do it in a good
color
x3
is equal to
five
plus two
x four
and then we get x one
x one
is equal to
two
minus x two
2 minus 2x2 sorry 2 minus 2
x2
plus
sorry
minus 3
x4 right i just subtracted these from
both sides of the equation
now this right here is essentially as
far as we can go to the solution of the
system of equations i can pick really
any values for my free variables i can
pick any values for my x2s and my x4s
and i can solve for an x3 but what i
want to do right now is write this in a
slightly different form so that we can
visualize a little bit better and of
course it's always hard to visualize
things in four dimensions but so we can
visualize things a little bit better as
to kind of the set of this solution so
let's write it this way
if i were to write it in vector form
our solution is the vector x1
x2
x3
x4
and what is it equal to
what is it equal to
well it's equal to
let me write it like this
it's equal to i'm just rewriting i'm
just essentially rewriting this solution
set in vector form so x1 is equal to
2 let me write a column there
plus
x2 let me write it this way plus x2
times something
plus x4
times
plus x4 times something so how do i so
x1
x1 is equal to 2
minus 2 times x2 or plus x2 times minus
2. so i put a minus 2 there and then i
can say plus x4 times -3 so i can put a
minus 3 there
this right here these first entries
of these vectors just literally
represent that equation right there x1
is equal to 2 plus x2 times -2 plus x4
times minus 3.
now what does x3 equal
what does x3 equal
x3
x3 is equal to 5
put that 5 right there plus x4 times 2
plus x4 times 2.
x2 doesn't apply to it so we can just
put a 0. 0 times x2 plus 2 times x4 now
what does x2 equal well you could say x2
is equal to 0
plus 1 times x2 plus 0 times x4 right x2
is just equal to x2 it's a free variable
and similarly what is x4 equal to x4 is
equal to
plus 0 times x2 plus 1 times x4
now what does this do for us well all of
a sudden here we've expressed our
solution set as essentially the linear
combination of well
of the linear combination of three
vectors this is a vector in you could
view it as a almost a coordinate in in
either position vector it is a it is a
vector in r4 you can use a position
vector or a coordinate in r4 and then
you could say look our solution set is
essentially this is an r4 each of these
have four components but you can imagine
it in r3
that i have my solution set is equal to
some vector
some vector there that you know that's
the vector think of it as a position
vector would be the coordinate two comma
zero comma five comma zero
which obviously this is four dimensions
right there but it's equal to multiples
of these two vectors
so let's call this vector right here
let's call this vector vector a
and let's call
this vector right here
vector b
so our solution set is all of is all of
this point which is right there or i
guess we could call that that position
vector
right that position vector will look
like that or you're starting at the
origin right there plus multiples of
these two guys so if a if this is vector
a actually do vector a in a different
color
vector a looks like that so let's say
vector a looks like that and then vector
b
looks like that this is vector b
and this is vector a and i don't know if
this is going to be easier or harder for
you to visualize because obviously we're
dealing in four dimensions right here
and i'm kind of just drawing it on a
two-dimensional surface but what you can
imagine is is that the solution set is
equal to this fixed point this position
vector plus linear combinations of a and
b
and we're dealing of course in r4 let me
write that down we're dealing in r4 but
linear combinations of a and b are going
to create a plane right you can just
take you know you can
you can multiply a times two and b times
three or a times minus one and b times
minus a hundred and you can just keep
adding and subtracting these linear
combinations of a and b and they're
going to con construct a plane
that contains the position vector that
contains the point two zero five zero so
the solution for this for this for these
three equations with four unknowns is a
plane in r4
a plane
in r4 and i know that's really hard to
visualize and maybe i'll do another one
in three dimensions but hopefully this
at least gets you a gives you a decent
understanding of what an augmented
matrix is what reduced row echelon form
is and what are kind of the valid
operations i can perform on a matrix
without kind of messing up the system